สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะ
ขอต้อนรับทุกคนนะคะเข้าสู่ห้องเรียน
คนรไยห้องเรียนภาษาไทยค่ะค่ะแล้วก็ในวัน
นี้นะคะครูปุ๊กกับครูชิก็มาพบกับทุกๆคน
ค่ะในวันอะไรคะครูชิวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
ครูจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันจันทร์ที่
25 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนธันวาคมค่ะปี
พุทธศักราชที่เท่าไหร่คะพุทธศักราช
2566 ปีคริสตศักราชที่เท่าไหร่คะ
2023 ค่ะค่ะวันนี้ก็เป็นวันคริสต์มาสนะ
วันจันทร์ที่ 25 นะเดือนท่านธันวาคมปี
พุทธศักราช
2566 ปีคริสตศักราช
2023 ค่ะค่ะ Merry คริสต์มาสค่ะ Merry
คริสตมาสค่ะสุขสันวันคริสต์มาส
อื้อหือขอให้ทุกคนมีความ
สุขสุขภาพแข็งแรง
อ่าร่ำรวยค่ะมีเงินมีทองเยอะๆค่ะ
ทำอะไรก็สำเร็จอ่าคิดหวังอะไรก็ขอให้ได้
สมความปรารถนาก็คือคิดอยากได้ก็ได้
อ่าก็คิดว่าไม่ว่านักเรียนนะคะแล้วก็
ครอบครัวด้วยนะคะก็ให้มีความสุขนะคะพบแต่
สิ่งที่ดีๆนะคะดีๆดีๆเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยวัน
นี้วันคริสต์มาสโอ้โหครูชีเนี่ยแต่งนะ
แบคกราวข้างหลังนี่คริสต์มาสเลยนะอืใช่
ค่ะูชิเนี่ยเตรียมมาแบบเอ่อคูชิเนี่ยต้อง
มีค่ะคริสต์มาสเนี่ยทุกปีนะคะแล้วบางที
เนี่ยเราอาจจะเสริมความสวยงามของเอ่อ
คริสต์มาสของเราครูชิก็เปลี่ยนไปแต่ละวัน
ไม่เหมือนกันโอ้
โอโหของครูปุ๊กเนี่ยเหมือนเดิม
ค่ะไม่เป็นไรครูปุ๊กเพราะตอนเนี้ยครูปุ๊ก
มีเทคโนโลยีมี
คอมพิวเตอร์อือฮึกครูปุ๊กก็สามารถจัดเอ่อ
Merry คริสมาสแบบคอมพิวเตอร์ได้
ออ 2 นี่ 2  0  2
4 ต้อนรับนะต้อนรับปีใหม่ใช่ค่ะนะก็ถ้า
คริสต์มาสแล้วก็ใกล้ที่จะเป็นปีใหม่แล้ว
เนา 20  2  3 ก็บ๊าย
บายนะเปลี่ยนเป็น 20  2  4 ใช่ค่ะแล้วแน่
นอนค่ะในประเทศไทยนะคะทุกๆจังหวัดทุกๆ
สถานที่ที่มีห้างสรรพสินค้าใหญ่ๆนะคะก็
ต้องมีการจัดงานปีใหม่แล้วก็นับถอยหลังนะ
คะอืเอ้ยนับเยอะมั้ยคะตั้งแต่ 100 มั้ย
[เพลง]
98 ทีเนี้ยนักเรียนของเราเนี่ยบางคนบอก
โอ๊ยผมได้ยินคำว่าเคาดาวแต่ไม่เข้าใจ
เคาดาวก็บอกเคาดาวเป็นภาษาอังกฤษค่ะแต่
พูดแบบคนไทยเราไม่ไม่มี accent นะนะเราก็
บอก
เดานับถอยหลัง 10  9  8  7  6  5  4  3  2
1  0
พึ่งปึ้งมีพุด้วยูชิ
ใช่ค่ะหรือว่าภาษาไทยใช้คำว่าดอกไม้ไฟล
ดอกไม้ไฟเนาะแต่ว่าคนไทยก็พูดพุพุใช่
พุถูกต้องครูปุ๊เ้าถ้าเกิดฉลองปีใหม่
เคาดาวแล้วเนี่ยไม่มีเฉลิมฉลองไม่มีพุ
เนี่ยไม่สนุกเลยค่ะ
อืมใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าสวยใช่มั้ยคะถูกต้องค่ะ
แต่วันนี้เนี่ยเราจะมีการชวนนักเรียน
เนี่ยมาเช็ดค่ะเช็คจุดที่เราจะไปเคาดาว
กันอ๋อเราจะไปเช็คอินไปมั้ยไป
ค่ะปกติแล้วเนี่ยเวลาที่เรานับถอยหลังนะ
แต่ละปีเนี่ยโอ้โหก็จะมีแบบฮือฮามากๆนะคะ
โดยเฉพาะบางทีเนี่ยนักเรียนเนี่ยอยู่
ประเทศต่างๆใช่มั้ยเราอาจอาจจะเอ่อนับถอย
หลังหรือเคาดาวเนี่ยก่อนประเทศไทยค่ะครู
ปุ๊ใช่ค่ะครูปุ๊กก็จะเคยเห็นเนาะอย่าง
ซิดนีย์อย่างเงี้ยนะเขาก็จะมีแบบนับถอย
หลังก่อนเราเพราะว่าเวลาเนาะเวลาเค้า
เนี่ยเร็วกว่าเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเราจะ
เคาท์ดาวน์ก็ตอนเที่ยงคืนใช่มยเวลา
ซินเดอเรลล่า time เนี่ยนะก็เอ่อซินนี่
เขาก็ก่อนเรานะหลายๆประเทศก็ก่อนเรานะ
เราก็ต้องรอค่ะถ้าเกิดเนี่ยตอนนี้เรามี
เทคโนโลยีใช่มั้ยแล้วถ้ามีโดนเนี่ยบิน
ขึ้นไปแล้วก็เก็บภาพตอนช่วงเคาท์ดาวนะเรา
จะเห็นพุมาจากหลายๆสถานที่ใน
กรุงเทพฯอืเพราะว่าจริงๆแล้วอ่ะหลายๆ
จังหวัดเขาก็จุดพลุเหมือนกันเนาะแต่ทีนี้
เนี่ยเนื่องจากว่ากรุงเทพเนี่ยเป็นเมือง
หลวงอนะของประเทศไทยก็เลยมี 5 สรรพสินค้า
ใหญ่ๆเนี่ยหลายๆห้างค่ะนะพออยู่หลายๆห้าง
อยู่ไม่ไกลจากกันเท่าไหร่เนาะเวลามีการ
ที่จัดงานก็เลยมีจัดงานจัดงานจัดงานเวลา
เรามองแบบถ้ามองจากข้างบนลงมาเนี่ยโอ้โห
ก็น่าจะสวยมาก
เนาะใช่ค่ะแล้วก็เอ่อเมื่ออาทิตย์ที่แล้ว
ค่ะอาทิตย์ที่แล้วที่ผ่านมานะคะก็มีเอ่อ
ทททหรือการท่องเที่ยวแห่งประเทศไทยนะมีเห
นานนะนี่ๆที่มีรูปนี้นี่สัญลักษณ์ของททท
โอ้มีวัดอรุณกับเรือหงส์นะอันนี้รูปวัด
อรุณกับเรือเรือหงส์นะคะอันนี้เป็น
สัญลักษณ์หรือเป็นโลโก้ของการท่องเที่ยว
ของประเทศไทยค่ะใช่ค่ะคนที่ดูแลเกี่ยวกับ
จัดกิจกรรมหลายๆอย่างนะเพื่อให้คนต่าง
ชาติเนี่ยนะจากนักเรียนอย่างเงี้ยมา
เที่ยวประเทศไทยนะเขาก็จะมีการจัดงานจัด
อะไรแบบนี้นะแล้วก็มีหน่วยงานของ
กรุงเทพมหานครเพราะว่าจัดในกรุงเทพมหานคร
ใช่มั้ยแต่ของต่างจังหวัดงอันนี้ของโคราช
นะคะเาก็จะมีขึ้นขึ้นบอร์ดโชว์มาเรื่อยๆ
ค่ะว่ามีจังหวัดไหนจัที่ไหนมีอะไรบ้างทอพ
ททเมาพรีเซนค่ะมามาโฆษณาว่าแต่ละที่จะมี
การแสดงอะไรยกตัวอย่างเช่นอันนี้เป็นจุด
ไฮไลท์
ค่ะนะเป็นจุดที่หลายๆคนเนี่ยจะไปเที่ยว
แล้วก็จะไปเคาท์ดาวน์ที่นี่ใช่มยใช่ค่ะ
แล้วที่วัดอรุณนะคะจะมีการจัดงานใหญ่แล้ว
ก็มีเอ่อเนี่ยเห็นมเา้าบอกว่าเป็น aming
Thailand เดา
2024 นะคะแล้วก็มีโปรเจควิจิตรอรุณออ
ชื่อของวัดอรุณอรุณแปลว่าอะไรอ่ะแปลว่า
ตอนรุ่งเช้าเริ่มเริ่มจะเช้ามีแสงแดดขึ้น
มานิดหน่อยก่อนค่ะแล้วก็ค่อยๆขึ้นนะก็คือ
แสงจากตอนเช้าค่ะอรุณ
อ่าแล้วที่นี่นะคะทททบอกว่าเขาจะจัดพุค่ะ
ประมาณ 9 เซต 9 ชุดด้วยกันโอ้มี 9 ชุด
ปึ่งชุดที่เกี่ยวกับตอนเช้านะคะมีชุดแบบ
อรุณรุ่งอ่าหรือมีอีกชุดนึงก็จะเป็น
เกี่ยวกับเรื่องความเจริญเห็นมก็ก็เหมือน
กับอวยพรไปด้วยนะออืก็ไม่ต้องเขียนใน
การ์ดใช่มั้นะว่า Happy  New  Year ตึ๊ดๆ
ๆๆเนี่ยไม่ต้องใช่มั้ยต้องค่ะแล้วเขาก็จะ
มีอันนี้ค่ะมีการแสดงโขนขึ้มา
ออเป็นยักษ์อืมรามเกียนใช่มั้ยรายนะถ้า
เราไปวัดอรุณเราจะเจอยักษ์ 2 ตัวนี้ยืน
อยู่ตรงหน้าประตูวัดนะคะ
อ้าวสีเขียวเนี่ยชื่อทศกรณ์ค่ะอ่าทศกร
เนี่ยถือว่าเป็นหัวหน้ายักษ์เลยนะยักษ์
เป็นแบบตำแหน่งใหญ่มาก
อืทดแปลว่า 10 อืนะมี 10 หน้ามีมี 10 มี
10 หน้าใช่มั้ยอือใช่แเก็จะเห็นหน้า
ยักษ์แล้วก็มีข้างบนยักษ์ๆๆๆๆๆเงี้ยอหน้า
เยอะค่ะอมีด้านหลังรอบๆอีกนะมีทั้งหมด 10
หน้านะคส่วนยักษ์สีขาวเนี่ยสหัสสเดใชะค่ะ
อันนี้ก็เก่งค่ะเป็นยักษ์ที่เก่งทั้ง 2
ตัวแล้วก็มีอาวุธเป็นกระบองด้วยใช่มั้ยคะ
ใช่ค่ะกระบองเพชรค่ะอือ่าชี้คนตายได้อ่า
แล้วอยากให้คนตายเนี่ยฟื้นกลับมามีชีวิต
นะก็สามารถใช้อีกด้านนึงชี้ชี้ชี้ไปให้นะ
เหมือนกระบองใช่มยมี 2 ด้านด้านบนด้าน
ล่างนะด้านล่างอาจจะชี้ไปแล้วก็ตายูชิตาย
เออพอเอาอีกด้านด้านบนชี้ปึ๊บอ้าฝื้นขึ้น
มาโอ้โหอันนี้ต้องไปเรียนเกี่ยวกับเอ่อ
วัฒนธรรมประวัติศาสตร์ไทยนะคะจะมีเรื่อง
พวกนี้เรียนอยู่ในชั่วโมงวัฒนธรรมไทยอหนุ
ค่ะค่ะนะช่วงนี้ค่ะช่วงนี้ถ้าเกิดครูปุ๊ก
นั่งเรือผ่านเจ้าพระยานะคะแม่น้ำ
เจ้าพระยาค่ะนะคครูปุ๊กก็จะเห็นว่าวัด
อรุณของเราตอนนี้นะคะเริ่มมีแสงสีค่ะ
อื้อหือนะฮะนะเปิดไฟเห็นมั้ยผู้คนเริ่มไป
เที่ยวมีเวทเวทีเห็นมั้ยคะอ่า
อ่าคือไปเที่ยววัดอรุณเนี่ยไปเที่ยวได้
ทั้งกลางวันและกลางคืนนะตอนนี้เห็นมั้ยคะ
มีติดไฟเิด 24 ชั่วโมงเหรอคะเอ่อช่วงนี้
นะคะเปิดจนถึง 2:00 นมคะประมาณอืเอ้านึก
ว่าจะเปิดถึงเช้าวันปีใหม่ไม่วันปีใหม่
นี่เปิดยาวค่ะแต่ก่อนหน้านี้มาเปิดแค่นี้
ค่ะแล้วก็มีการจุดพุแบบนี้เห็นมอืนี่นี่
ชุดที่แบบอรุณรุ่งพระอาทิตย์ขึ้นนะมีแสง
สว่างขึ้นวัดอรุณก็จะโดดเด่นอันนี้เนี่ย
เขาบอกว่าจะมีเรือท่องเที่ยวนะซึ่งถ้า
เกิดบางคนเนี่ยอาจจะชอบกินอาหารนั่งเรือ
แล้วก็กินอาหารแล้วก็
ชม
เจ้าพระยาซ้ายขวาเจ้าพระยาแล้วก็โอ้โหมี
ความสุขกินอาหารไปด้วยวันปีใหม่เนี่ยมี
พิเศษก็คือได้ดูพุที่วัดอรุณค่ะอืมอาจจะ
ไม่ใช่แค่ที่วัดอรุณด้วยเนาะนะนักเรียน
ถ้าเกิดว่ามาซื้อตั๋วกินกินอาหารบนเรือนะ
แล้วก็ล่องแม่น้ำเจ้าพระยาล่องหมาถึงว่า
ไปเรื่อยๆอ่ะค่ะอยู่บนเรือแล้วเรือก็ไปไป
ไปผ่านวัดอรุณผ่านวัดพระแก้วอะไรแบบเนี้ย
เนาะก็จะทำให้นักเรียนเนี่ยเห็นโดยเฉพาะ
ตอนเที่ยงคืนค่ะนะอเขาก็จะจุดเคาท์ดาวไง
ก็จุดพุตอน
เคาดาวก็เอ่อจัดงานที่มีพุเนี่ยก็คือวัน
ที่ 31 ใช่มั้ยวันสุดท้ายของปี
2566 แล้วก็รอจนถึงวันที่ 1 มกราคม
2567 เห็นมั้ยเห็นมั้ยอ่าแล้วก็เค้าก็จะ
เริ่มเคาดาวตั้งแต่ประมาณเนาะเกือบอือื 23
น 50 เท่าไหร่
ดีเพราะว่าเนี้ยเขาจะจุดนาน 5 นาทีค่ะอ
ของที่นี่นะคะ 5 นาทีประมาณนี้จะเริ่ม
ตั้งแต่พอเที่ยงคืใช่มั้ยเอไม่ใช่ 5 นาที
ต่อเนื่อง 7 นาทีค่ะ 7 นาที 7 นาทีใช่เขา
ก็ต้องนับก่อนเนอะแล้วก็พอนับ 10  9  8  7
6  5  4  3  2  1
ปุ้งจะมีชุดแบบสยามเมืองยิ้ม
เอ้อชื่อเยอะค่ะชื่อพุนะคะยังไม่ยังไม่พอ
แค่นั้นค่ะเห็นมั้ยมันจะมีพุแบบหลากหลาย
นะคะแต่ที่สำคัญเนี่ยครูชิต้องให้ดูอัน
นี้ค่ะครูปุ๊อะไระอะไรงานเไม่ได้มีแค่
นั้นอันนั้นโขนใช่มั้ยที่คณเนี่ยใส่หัว
แล้วก็มาเต้นตึดๆๆๆอันนั้นโขนอันนี้เรา
เรียกว่าหุ่นละครเล็ก
อืหุ่นละครเล็กก็จะมีคนเนี่ยใส่ชุดสีดำ
เนี่ยคอยเชิดเป็นหุ่นหุ่นกระบอกเนาะใช่
อ่าน่าจะตอนอันนี้ค่ะคุฑพญาครุฑเห็นมั้ย
คะวัดอรุณนักเรียนจะเห็นครุฑกับนาคเยอะนะ
ไปที่วัดอรุณน่าจะเป็นเรื่องครุฑทะเลาะ
กับนาค
ค่ะเอ้าเ้าครุฑก็ตัวเล็กๆนาคตัวใหญ่กว่า
ครุฑก็กินนาคไม่ได้สิคะูชิเอ้ากินได้ค่ะ
คุฑเสามารถแปลงร่างให้ใหญ่ได้อืทำตัวให้
ใหญ่เล็กได้ค่ะแล้วที่สำคัญเนี่ยเขเป็น
พี่น้องกันด้วยไงเอ้อพี่น้องเรียกว่าลูก
พี่ลูกน้องโอใช่อของพี่ลูกของน้องใช่นะ
เป็นลูกของพี่กับลูกของน้องแล้วก็มา
ทะเลาะกัน
นะยังไม่พอค่ะยังไม่หมดแค่นั้นค่ะเายังมี
นี่ค่ะวง Symphony ออร์เคสตร้าด้วยว้าว
แล้วก็มีออคนที่มาร้องนะใช่ค่ะไม่รู้จะ
ร้องโล่าหรือ
เปล่านะคะอันนี้เป็นวงฟี่ออร์เคสตร้านะคะ
แล้วก็มีนักร้องนักแสดง
อืมโอ้โหนี่คนนี้เก่งเก่งเนี่ยเก่งสมชื่อ
เลยคนนี้ใช่มั้ยใช่เไปเติมเขี้ยวแบบยักษ์
ด้วยนะแล้วก็ชอบชอบคือเมีเสียงที่มี
พาเวอร์ชอบแต่งตัวเป็นยักษ์แบบนี้
อื
นี่นะคะแล้วก็ร้องแบบ
เสียงสุดยอดอันนี้อันนี้ที่วัดอรุณนะนะคะ
เห็นมั้ยอือหือค่ะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยสจใช่
นะคะในบริเวณแม่น้ำเจ้าพระยายังไม่หมดแค่
นั้นค่ะนะคะยังมีอันนี้อีกค่ะ
ไอคอนสยามโ้อ้อันนี้ก็เป็นห้างสรรพสินค้า
ที่ใหญ่มากนะแล้วก็อยู่ติดกับแม่น้ำ
เจ้าพระยาถูกต้องนะคะเราต้องบอกเลยว่าไอ้
ไคอนสยามนี่เค้าก็ไม่น้อยหน้าค่ะไอคอน
สยามนี่เค้าก็บอกค่ะว่าก็จะมีการจัดงานนะ
คะเคาดาวเหมือนกันแล้วก็เอ่อมีมีนักร้อง
นักแสดงมาเหมือนกัน
อืแล้วที่สำคัญเครูปุ๊กเค้าจะจุดทุ 50,000
ดอกโอ้หูเยอะมากเลย
อื้อหือ
จุดกันแบบโอ้โหอลังการนะฮะจุดยาวเนี่ย
1,400 มค่ะอือหือ
โอ้โหคือแม่น้ำเจ้าพยะนี่เอ่อไอคอนสยามก็
จุดแบบ
โอ้โหยาวไปเลยค่ะ 1,400 มตตลอดแม่น้ำ
เจ้าพระยาเพราะฉะนั้นครูกถ้าซื้อตั๋วตั๋ว
เรือเมกินอาหารล่องเจ้าพระยาเนี่ยโอ้โหโ
คุ้มเนาะได้ดูพุหลายๆที่
เลยต้องเห็นมั้ยที่นี่ก็มีนักร้องนักแสดง
มาเหมือนกันโอ้โหแล้วดูสิคะเค้าไม่ใช่
เป็นแค่ดาราไทยค่ะเค้ามีดาราเกาหลีมาด้วย
อืมีก็อเซว่นมาด้วยเห็นมั้ยอแล้วก็นัก
ร้องนักแสดงไทยมีเอ่อตารางงานตั้งแต่ 29
30  31  31 เี่อยู่ยาวจนเคาดาวจุดพุบึ้ม
ๆๆๆโอๆๆ
ๆจุดพุรุนแรงไปหน่อยค่ะอันนี้ก็คือที่
เอ่อกรุงเทพฯนะคะกรุงเทพฯยังไม่หมดแค่นี้
ค่ะมีที่ไหนอีกคะูชิ
เมกะบางนาโ้อ้อันนี้ก็ใหญ่เหมือนกันเป็น
ห้างใหญ่เหมือนกันอื้อหือนะคะเมกับางนาก็
เป็นห้างที่ขายเฟอร์นิเจอร์ต่างๆเยอะแยะ
นะอันนี้ก็จัดด้วยก็มีนักร้องนักแสดงมีวง
ดนตรีมีจุดพุนะคะแล้วที่ขาดไม่ได้ค่ะนี่
ค่ะเซ็นทรั World อออันนี้ก็เป็นจุดศูนย์
รวมของเอ่อนักท่องเที่ยวอยู่แล้วเนาะ
เซ็นทรั World เหมือนเมื่อก่อนไม่มีไม่มี
ไอคอนสยามก็ที่นี่ก็จะเป็นแลนด์มาร์กอที่
สำคัญเลยเลยแหละ
เแล้วูพุกดูเซ็นทรัลเนี่ยห้างสรรพสินค้า
เซ็นทรัลมีที่จังหวัดไหนก็จะมีการนับถอย
หลังนะคะมีเคาท์ดาวน์หมดนะคะเวทีใหญ่แบบ
นี้เพราะอะไรเพราะทุกปีทุกปีตอนเนี้ยเข้า
ฤดูหนาวใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะก็จะมีแบบเบียร์
กาเด้นค่ะ
อืมเา้าก็จะมีพื้นที่ที่ขายเบียนเนาะแล้ว
ก็จะมีผู้หญิงสวยๆมาเค้าเรียกเด็กเชียร์
เบียร์มาเชียร์ให้คนซื้อเบียร์ดื่ม
โอถูกต้องค่ะฟังเพลงแล้วก็กินอาหาร
อืนะดีค่ะบรรยากาศดีค่ะ
นะคนเยอะคนเยอะที่
นี่แล้วก็เอ่อพอมีเบียร์การ์เด้นคือช่วง
เนี้ยมีเบียร์การ์เด้นอยู่แล้วแต่วันที่
วันปีใหม่เนี่ยจะมีการเคาท์ดาวน์มีนัก
แสดงมีดนตรีแบบนี้ทุกวันนะมีแสงสีเสียง
แบบนี้ค่ะนะที่เซ็นทรัลเวินะแต่พุนี่ก็คง
จะวันเดียวเนาะวันที่ 37 ไปวันที่ 1
เนี่ยนะถึงจะจุดพุพุเราแล้วก็เซ็นทรัล
เชียงใหม่อื
อ่าที่เชียงใหม่นี่ก็จะมีหินเหล็กไแต่อัน
นี้เนี่ยเค้ามีเบียร์การ์เด้นใช่มั้ยอัน
นี้มีเบียร์
ช้างเชียงใหม่เค้ามีหลายเบียร์ค่ะแต่เ้า
จัดงานแยกกันจัดงานแยกกันคนละห้างอเพราะ
ว่าที่เซ็นทรัลเวเป็นห้างนึงแต่ว่ามี
เบียร์หลายยี่ห้อขายด้วยกันนะเป็นนะ
โออันนี้ก็ใครบริษัทไหนก็จัดของตัวเองใช่
มยถูกต้องค่ะนะคะอันนี้ก็จะเป็นแบบเอ่อ
ของเบียร์ช้างนะเบียร์ช้างก็จะไปที่เอ่อ
เซ็นทรัลเชียงเชียงใหม่ที่เชียงใหม่ก็ยัง
มีอีกนะคะา่าอินเตอร์เดาวอันนี้จัดหลาย
วันนะอันนี้จัดที่โอ้ขอโทษขอโทษเอ่ออัน
นี้จัดที่วันอันนี้เป็นเป็นสถานที่เอ่อ
ที่เคไปต้องต้องบอกว่าเป็นสถานที่ที่เค้า
ไปเช็คอินกันบ่อยๆนะคสถานที่ท่องเที่ยวนะ
เพราะว่าวัยรุ่นวัยรุ่นชอบค่ะอไปเซลฟี่ไป
ถ่ายรูป
เนาะถูกต้องอันนี้เนี่ยจัดตั้งแต่ 28 ค่ะ
อือฮึ 28  29  30  31 นะจนถึงนะเคาดาวบุม
ใช่ค่ะแล้วก็
เอ่อยังมีอีกค่ะเชียงใหม่มีหลายที่อันนี้
เบียรสิงหอืนะคเบียร์สิงหก็อยู่ศูนย์การ
ค้าเบย่านะเป็นศูนย์การค้าใหญ่เหมือนกัน
อ่าก็จะมีนักร้องนักแสดงเหมือนกันค่ะครู
ปุ๊กอือใครเป็นคนที่ชอบนะนักร้องนักแสดง
ชอบคนไหนก็ไปเลย
ค่ะคนละคนไปคนละที่นะคือเชียงใหม่เขาก็มี
หลายที่นะคะอืเอ่อแล้วก็เอ่อต้องบอกเลย
ค่ะนอกจากเอ่อนอกจากของเอกชนนะบริษัทต่าง
ๆห้างร้านต่างๆแล้วเนี่ยก็ยังมีของเทศบาล
เมืองเชียงใหม่ออันนี้คือของเชียงใหม่จัด
เองใช่ค่ะอยู่ตรงประประตูท่าแพครูปุ๊กนัก
เรียนไปเนี่ยต้องผ่านแน่ๆจะเป็นสถานที่
ที่คือเป็นที่สำหรับจัดงานเลยไม่ว่าจะ
เทศกาลปีใหม่สงกรานต์นะประตูท่าแพนี่ต้อง
มาที่นี่เลยเห็นมยแล้วเจัดเป็นซุ้มเหมือน
ซุ้มประตูค่ะให้เดินแบบลอดใต้ประตูนี้ไป
นะฮะตามความเชื่อของคนล้าน
นาน
ปลอดภัยสุขภาพแข็งแรงอือายุนานๆใช่มยแล้ว
ก็ร่ำรวยเงินทองนะโต้องมีทุกอย่างค่ะแล้ว
ก็ต้องมีผ่านแต่ละประตูเนี่ยนะผ่านทุก
ประตูไปเลยค่ะจะได้โชคดีทุกอย่าง
ครบิงสวยนะติดไฟเนี่ยตอนนี้เติดแล้วค่ะ
แล้วก็ติดยาวไปจนถึงปีใหม่นู่นออที่ 7
สวยมากใช่ค่ะก็เื่อใจะไปเก็บูปเก็บภาพ
ก่อนเนาะเพราะว่าช่วงถ้าปีใหม่แล้วเนี่ย
คนเยอะมากๆแน่นอนโอ้โหนี่ก็มีนักท่อง
เที่ยวไปเยอะเลยใช่ค่ะขณะตอนนี้เนี่ยยัง
ไม่ได้เคาท์ดาวน์เลยนะคนก็เริ่มเต็มถนน
ะถ้าเคาท์ดาวน์อีกคนจะเต็มขนาดไหนใช่ค่ะ
แล้วเราลองไปที่อื่นมั่งดูไปก็มีแต่ชาว
ต่างชาตินะหาคนไทยเนี่ยแทบไม่มีเลยอันนี้
เซ็นทรัลค่ะเซ็นทรัล
เอ่ออันนี้อันนี้มีแบบเอ่อเชียงใหม่เอ่อ
ที่เชียงใหม่ก็มีอีกที่นึงที่แสดงแล้วก็
มีการโชว์น้ำพุด้วยนะเชียงใหม่ก็มีหลาย
ที่นะอือฮึเพราะว่าเป็นที่สถานที่ท่อง
เที่ยวเนาะคนเอ่อนักท่องเที่ยวเนี่ยชอบไป
เชียงใหม่กันเยอะไงถ้าจัดที่เดียวเนี่ย
เดี๋ยวนักท่องเที่ยวไปกันเยอะเกินไปมัน
ต้องกระจายคนหลายๆที่จะได้ไม่ไปเวียดกัน
นะอ่านักเรียนต้องแยกนะอันนี้เราเรียกว่า
น้ำพุอันนี้เราเรียกว่าพุ
อ่าน้ำพุเนี่ยมันจะเป็นน้ำที่พุ่งขึ้นมา
จากดินเนาน้ำพุ
อหาส่วนพุเนี่ยเป็นไฟดอกไม้นะหรือชื่อนึง
ก็คือดอกไม้ไฟอือเพราะมันเหมือนดอกไม้ใช่
มั้ยูปุ๊กใช่ค่ะมันจะเหมือนดอกไม้เพราะ
มันถูกยิงขึ้นไปแล้วมันจะไปแตกปุ้งกลาย
เป็นเหมือนดอกไม้อันนี้เป็นต้นเหรอใช่ค่ะ
เป็นก้านมันเหมือนก้านเหโอเคนะคะอันนี้ก็
คือที่เชียงใหม่นะต่อมาค่ะไปพัทยาบ้างอ่ะ
พัทยาใช่ค่ะพัทยาก็มีเหมือนกันค่ะ 29  30
31 นะคะก็มีเอ่อเคาดาวเหมือนกันอันนี้
เนี่ยน่าจะร่วมกับ mon  29 อือฮึก็มีนัก
ร้องนักแสดงของอืของเอ่อของแต่ละค่ายไป
เแต่ละกลุ่มนะเเขียนว่าช่องฟรีก็คือดูฟรี
ด้วยค่ะเมื่อกี้ถูกต้องนะคส่วนอันนี้ก็
เป็นเอ่อเซ็นทรัพัทยาค่ะ
อุ้ยูชิจะจะจะขยายที่ีไรมามาแบบขอ
อภัยเซ็นทรัลพัทยาโอเคนะคจริงๆมีหลาย
จังหวัด
นะต่อมาค่ะ
นะอันนี้ที่โคราชโคราชบ้าน
เฮาบ้านแใช่มั้โคราชบ้านเห่านะโคราชก็ก็
เอ่อมีที่สนามเอ่อสนามหน้าศาลกการจังหวัด
ค่ะอนี่ย่ามคนก็เยอะนะใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าตรง
นั้นเป็นอนุสาวรีย์ของย่าโมด้วยค่ะอ
อนุสาวรีผ
สุรนารี
นะถัด
ไปนะคะอันนี้เนี่ยเอ่อออันนี้ก็เป็น
เซ็นทรัแต่อันนี้ที่จังหวัดภูเก็ต
นะที่จังหวัดภูเก็ตนะก็ต้องมาดูเอาว่า
ศิลปินคนไหนที่เราชอบมั้ยนะหรือไม่ชอบก็
ไม่เป็นไรแต่ว่าไปดูก่อนหรือไม่รู้จักก็
ไปดูก่อนค่ะอันอันนี้ที่หัวหินค่ะหัวหิน
อ่าคนก็เยอะเหมือนกันนะดูดิคนยืนดูพุเต็ม
เลยใช่ๆเพราะว่าปีใหม่ไงไปเคาดาวนะแล้วก็
ยังมีอีกหลายจังหวัดค่ะขอนแก่นนะคะเอ่อไป
ทางอีสานที่ใช่มั้ยก็มีขอนแก่นมีนครพนมชม
อะไรนะชมแม่น้ำโงแม่น้ำโผงอืใช่
อืคือแถบแถบอีสานก็มีหลายนะคะแถบภาคเหนือ
ภาคเหนือเนี่ยไม่ใช่เชียงใหม่อย่างเดียว
ใช่มั้ยยังมีเชียงรายนะคะยังมีแม่ฮ่องสร
ใช่จริงๆก็คือจัดมีทุกจังหวัดค่ะนักเรียน
อยู่ตรงไหนก็ลองเช็คจังหวัดที่ตัวเองอยู่
เนาว่าว่ามีการจัดเคาท์ดาวน์ที่ไหนนะอาจ
จะเป็นศาลากลางจังหวัดนะก็คือเป็นศูนย์
ที่เอ่อทำงานของ goverment ของรัฐบาลนะก็
จะมีลานกว้างๆให้จัดมีเวทีมีคอนเสิร์ตนะ
แล้วก็มีเคาท์ดาวน์อาจจะมีจุดพรุทุกที่
ค่ะนะยิงดอกไม้ไฟบุง
ุคือง่ายๆถ้าเป็นของรัฐบาลเนี่ยก็จะจัด
ที่แถวๆศาลากลางจังหวัดนะแถวๆในตัวเมือง
จังหวัดนั้นๆนะแต่ถ้าเป็นของเอกชนก็จัดใน
ห้างเช่นห้างเซ็นทรัลนะคะก็อย่างพัทยานี่
เมีดนตรีมาเป็นเป็นเดือนเลยนะร่วม 2
เดือนใช่นะก็เป็นงานที่เขาจัดเพื่ออ่ะนัก
ท่องเที่ยวจะได้สนุก
ไงภาคใต้นอกจากภูเก็ตแล้วก็จะมีหาดใหญ่นะ
คะเมืองใหญ่ๆสำคัญำคัญที่นักเรียนไป
เที่ยวนะประจวบคีรีขันธ์นะคะชะอำอย่าง
เงี้ยโอ้โหคือสรุปว่านักเรียนไปเที่ยวที่
ไหนมีเคาท์ดาวน์ทุกที่ในประเทศไทยแน่ๆ
เพียงแต่จะเป็นงานเล็กงานใหญ่มีพุมากหรือ
พุน้อยที่แบบว่าอย่างที่เราเอามาใน
กรุงเทพฯเนี่ยเราก็เลือกมาที่เขามีเอ่อ
เา้าเปิดตัวว่าเขาจะแบบว่าเปิดพุแบบ
อลังการอลังการก็คือใหญ่มากเยอะมากอเยอะ
มากบางคนบอกว่ากลัวเรือคุณก็สามารถที่จะ
ขึ้นไปบนตึกนะรูปทอปอ่านะดาดฟ้าของโรงแรม
อย่างเงี้ยแล้วก็ไปกินข้าวแล้วก็ดูดอกไม้
ไฟที่เขาจุดกันเยอะๆนะเรายิ่งอยู่ที่สูงๆ
เนอะก็จะมองเห็นเยอะๆค่ะนะแต่วันนี้เนี่ย
เราน่าจะไปดูกันได้หรือยังอ่ะครูชิอ๋อมัน
หมดเวลาใช่มั้ยเอาเป็นว่าสรุปว่านักเรียน
สามารถไปเที่ยวที่ไหนแล้วก็ไปดู
เคาท์ดาวน์ที่นั่นเลยค่ะจะได้ไม่ต้องเสีย
เวลาไม่ต้องแบบมาที่นึงไปอีกที่นึงนะคะ
ทุกที่น่าจะมีนะคะอาจจะเล็กแต่ไม่เป็นไร
มีความสุขก็ขอให้ทุกคนมีความสุขในปีใหม่
ที่ใกล้จะมาถึงนะคะค่ะนะก็ขอให้นักเรียน
ทุกคนเ่ะมีสุขภาพแข็งแรงมีความสุขค่ะแล้ว
วันนี้เรา 2 คนลาไปก่อนค่ะพบกันใหม่คลิป
ต่อไปค่ะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ